Northern Pakistan is home to the
Himalayas the karakuram and the Hindu
Kush
three of the world's highest mountain
ranges
once a popular destination for thrilled
Seekers and Mountaineers the number of
visitors has plunged due to covid-19
pandemic and political instability some
people have started to return Reviving
the tourism sector which is a Lifeline
for communities
a beautiful region on Earth having
stunning valleys and Peaks which are the
key pull factors for the tourists both
local and foreigners tourism is the only
means from which we are earning a
livelihood as we don't have other
Industries to survive the literacy rate
is high in Northern Pakistan and most
people here speak English beautiful up
until now we've been there for three
weeks and we love it the people the
mountains we're Mountain lovers so yeah
it's the perfect country for us people
are very friendly and generous so
but locals say the government needs to
do more to increase Pakistan's appeal as
a tourist destination especially during
The Current financial crisis
tourism is the only quick and viable
solution to attract foreign guests who
can bring in dollars and that can help
Pakistan to overcome its crisis the
government should try to promote tourism
better infrastructure and incentives to
attract foreign tourists okay
just a few years ago it was a
multi-billion dollar industry with its
Rich cultural heritage diverse
Landscapes and natural beauty Pakistan
has the potential to generate tens of
billions of dollars from tourism however
successive governments have failed to
invest in developing this sector as a
result the Pakistan tourism Development
Corporation has virtually collapsed and
most of the properties have been
auctioned or leased to private companies
industry plays say the government needs
to offer incentives to Breathe new life
into the flagging tourism sector
Kamal
Valley Northern Pakistan